governor Kuroda was very clear in saying
that China was also one of the big
reasons they had to move its weakness
affecting everybody and one of the
problems the Chinese have had is that
their currency they went is tied to the
dollar let's take a look at what the
impact of that has been over the last
year we have seen the white line
shipping out of shanghai exports from
china on a regular decline than you see
in august the yellow line the UN gets
revalued it starts to move lower and we
start to see the exports from shanghai
flatten out and move higher so the
Chinese engaging in a little bit of
currency wars already as well and now we
want to know what happens next
Jeff for you is China going to be forced
to respond as well for now probably not
you know China and Japan they're more
complementary economies you know rather
than competitors you know that might
change in the future but I don't think
the PBOC will be too fussed about this
and also PBOC will still be worried
about you know how a sharper move low
and there going to be how much that
would contribute to capital outflows you
know so that's the other side of the
equation you can move your currency
lower but not too much because right now
the pressure for depreciation is not
engineered by Beijing but it's actually
people on shore
wanting to get their money out so a
different dynamic Jeffrey this is a
three tier system now it's getting quite
complicated and given that most of the
JD B's are held by Japanese what does
this mean for older people which
obviously are you know the bulk of the
Japanese population well firstly you
know that we have to be very careful
that negative rates are not going to be
charged on retail deposits and I think
right now we don't have to worry about
that I think in Denmark I'm the last
January about 90 so so you talked about
the tiered system that 97 percent of
Danish deposits site deposits were
charged negative but that wasn't passed
on but up ahead I think Japanese
companies they'll have to invest more
overseas and invest in risk capture
high-yield and also pay more wages to
the working force population so they can
pay more taxes or to fund the pensions
so overall who has a toughest job among
central banks and what does it mean for
your smartest play into 2016 I think all
central bankers will tell you they have
the
as jobs you know right now but if you
look at what separates the Fed now from
everyone else everyone else is trying to
ease said is actually trying to
normalize so I'm going up to Brian's
earlier point to the normal kind of
environment pricing I think what came
out of the Fed decision was they're not
really pushing back you know against
markets more conservative pricing right
now Brian and Robbie this is just one of
the many things that have over hung the
markets the other oil prices now US
companies very much affected by oil
prices it's an input cost for many of
the companies that you buy is that going
to change things if we have now put a
floor under oil as well you know when I
look at the dynamics between companies
who use the oil as their feedstock
versus those that benefit from a lower
oil price I'm kind of surprised by the
market's behavior it seems like right
now we're correlating lower oil prices
with the economy is tanking but three
quarters or two thirds of the US economy
is consumer and service led which would
benefit from lower oil prices so I'm a
little bit surprised that the market is
equating lower oil prices with
Armageddon or toward something horrible
are you making any investments because
of the huge drop in oil well I'd have to
say that as it relates to companies that
are earning money from producing oil
refining oil etc we're to a point now
where you have to look your what you see
earlier in the week you've had your
first oil EMP do an equity deal raise
equity to appease the bondholders and
stave off what most EMP companies were
heading toward which is zero for for an
equity price so that's a good sign as it
relates to the suppliers of oil in in
the world the United States is rolling
over in its production I think you'll
see probably a million barrels of oil a
day come out a u.s. production at the
same time you have the Saudi Arabians
and maybe the Russians beginning to talk
about hey is this really what we want I
think
neither of those countries want $30 oil
there they're hurting